now to a major hit in the race to
vaccinate america we are learning nearly
15 million doses of the johnson and
johnson vaccine were ruined
after a mix-up at a manufacturing plant
according to the new york times workers
confused the ingredients with those of
another vaccine that was made at the
plant
the astrazeneca version now the mistake
reportedly
does not affect any of the doses that
have already been shipped that's very
important to note
some future shipments from the baltimore
plant may be in question
while the fda investigates cbs news
visited that facility in january
we're joined now by dr anthony fauci he
is president biden's chief medical
advisor and the country's top expert on
infectious diseases
dr valjey it's always good to see you
this is certainly a little bit of a
setback for
people already very nervous about the
vaccine they're saying that it's human
error
and i think it's good that it was caught
but how concerned should people be how
concerned are you about this
well obviously you don't like to see
anything like this happening but you're
right gail
it was human error the fda is
investigating this that plant
has not yet been fully certified by the
fda
and as you pointed out correctly people
should realize that all the doses
that have been distributed to us and
have been administered did not come from
that plant
so this is not related in any way to any
of the j
j doses that people have already gotten
and what's going on there now as i
mentioned is being thoroughly
investigated by the fda
how does this happen when did the white
house become aware of it and how does it
happen
well you know human errors do happen and
you have checks and balances and the
good news about this despite the fact
that it's
really quite unfortunate that about 15
million doses
now are not going to be able to be used
but you do have checks and balances and
you see that and that's the reason why
the good news
is that it did get picked up and as i
mentioned that's the reason
nothing of what from that plant has gone
into anyone
that we've administered to i'm ready for
some good news
it's coming from pfizer this morning
pfizer is saying this
that their vaccine is 100 effective in
preventing severe
illness as defined by the cdc including
some of the cases in
south africa that has that very
troubling variant so does this mean that
pfizer is a better vaccine you know how
it goes anybody that's got the vaccine
the first question they asked dr fauci
which one did you get which one did you
get and did you have any reaction
does this mean pfizer is a better
vaccine than the rest
no it doesn't it just means they did a
test and the results of the test as you
mentioned gail are really very
encouraging
something that we suspected all along
that even though you don't have a
vaccine
directed specifically against the
variant you can get some pretty good
protection pfizer did the study it look
really good i would not be surprised at
all
if modana and other companies that did
the same thing would get similar results
as we've said when these came out all
three
of the vaccines that have an emergency
use authorization
from our fda are highly efficacious
vaccine so that's all good news and the
finds and news just now that you
mentioned
is just you know icing on the cake for
good news yeah i like icing
and i like we all like icing you know
what else like we like baseball's
opening day which happens to be today
spring break is also going on at the
moment a lot of people are going to be
gathering sunday for easter
you put that all together dr fauci and
i'm curious we heard the cdc director
talk of impending doom as people loosen
up and gather
do you share her concern well you know i
i don't know if i would use the word
impending doom i i you know if you talk
to to dr olinsky which we do every
single day
the point she's making is a very valid
point
we're seeing that cases that have
plateaued over the last couple of weeks
and now they're starting to inch up so
the point that she was making was very
valid
please be careful don't declare victory
prematurely
let's continue to abide by the public
health measures
that we all talk about because you know
we have so much in our favor tony what
we have
is we have three million people that are
getting vaccinated every single day
we have over 50 million people who have
been completely and fully vaccinated
97 others that have at least one dose of
vaccine
so every day that goes by we get more
and more protected
so what i say and what dr olenski is
saying is just
hold on for a bit longer because every
day is
more and more in our favor and don't
pull back prematurely
we're going to be able to pull back we
don't want people to believe
that we're going to be in this situation
forever we're not but don't pull back
prematurely
so dr fauci your nationals have an
opportunity to redeem themselves after a
last place finish
last season last place in their division
uh will you be attending a game
on the trajectory on i mean this
seriously and also a little bit not so
seriously but
do you see us on a trajectory where
you'll be at a baseball game this summer
yes i do definitely i love it
i love it and forget about last season
tony that
they're going to go right back to 2019
this year
that would be a world series
championship that's a big bold
prediction from our dr fauci
you heard it right here on cbs
we thank you it's always good to see you
and if you go the game everybody wear
your mouse we can't say it enough
i don't know how many times we need to
yeah
and distance and have fun and enjoy the
game